días lunes de resaca post festejos los
festejos se extendieron largo y fueron
intensos durante la noche en el obelisco
en los alrededores del obelisco Ese es
el centro del epicentro de Buenos Aires
hay muchos otros lugares de la capital
de la provincia de Buenos Aires y de
todo el país la gente celebró se
divirtió La pasó bien festejó disfrutó
El Triunfo de la selección y después
descansó hoy a la mañana arrancó una
jornada bastante normal con caras de
felicidad con varias camisetas de la
selección que a veces se pueden ver esta
zona de la ciudad que está alrededor mío
había sido zona de paso de los hinchas
que iban hacia el obelisco ahora está
esta parte ya está más limpia bastante
más demanda hubo es de la limpieza de
limpieza de la zona del epicentro del
obelisco donde hubo mucha intensidad
muchísimos festejos muchas celebración y
mucha alegría tal vez una limpieza que
va a tener que repetirse el día martes
cuando la Selección llegue de regreso a
Argentina
Bueno sobre eso le quería preguntar
natalio qué se espera precisamente para
el recibimiento de la selección
bueno se especulaba con que iban a
llegar el propio lunes el mismo lunes
pero se fue demorando la partida desde
Qatar porque se extendieron las
celebraciones allí También
estarían llegando Aproximadamente en
torno a las dos de la mañana hora de
Buenos Aires del día martes van a
trasladarse desde el Aeropuerto de
ezeiza que es a unos 30 km de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires a un predio que está muy
cercano de ese aeropuerto que tiene la
asociación del fútbol argentino donde
dormirán pasarán la noche y está
organizado que alrededor del mediodía
salgan en micros en una suerte de
caravana de festejo para llegar al
obelisco y es así que sean recibidos y
ovacionados por los hinchas por eso
decías antes que el obelisco que estaba
haciendo limpiado se tiene que preparar
otra vez para hacer el epicentro de los
festejos y recibir toda esa intensidad
de los hinchas